-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
We're in the house.
Thank you for watching at home.
Well, guys,
this is very exciting --
the new movie "The Batman"
has arrived in theaters
and is expected to make
over $100 million this weekend.
[ Oohs, cheering, and applause ]
So I guess we're cool
with bats again.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, in this movie,
Batman's just psyched
to fight anyone after two years
of "work from cave."
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
To celebrate the new movie,
AMC is selling
a special popcorn bucket
for just $27.
Take a look at this thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Aw.
-I have a feeling
you'll be seeing that taken
out of someone's house
on the next season
of "Queer Eye." It's like --
[ Laughter ]
[ English accent ]
I don't think you need this.
I think we can remove that.
I guess it's a cool idea,
though,
but it's still not as fun
as when I saw "Belfast"
and I ate popcorn
out of Judi Dench's head.
[ Laughter ]
-Aw.
-That was awesome.
It just made you enjoy
the movie that much more, yeah.
Let's get to some news.
Well, we all know that gas
prices have been going up,
but last night they surged
to the highest point
in nearly 10 years.
[ Booing ]
You know it's bad.
Instead of UberPool,
now there's UberPush.
[ Laughter ]
They go, "Where are you from?
Oh, cool."
Yeah, gas prices are up,
which means your coworker
who bikes in every day
just got even more annoying.
[ Laughter ]
"My legs are my gas tank."
Okay, buddy.
Of course,
gas prices have a lot to do
with what's happening in Ukraine
and, in the face
of growing criticism,
today Vladimir Putin blocked
every Russian citizen
from using Facebook.
-Ew!
-If you think Putin
is unhinged now,
wait 'til nobody remembers
his birthday.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, in Russia, the president
has to block Facebook.
Meanwhile, in America, Facebook
has to block the president.
[ Laughter ]
-I think it's very interesting.
-Come on.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That works.
Hey, I read that the Space Force
has plans to start
patrolling the area
around the moon.
[ Laughter ]
So the Pentagon said
there's a war in Europe
and the Space Force was like,
"We'll cover the moon."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I saw that Disney+
is going to launch
a cheaper, ad-supported option
on its platform.
I'm sure kids will be excited
to watch "Encanto" and hear --
♪ We don't talk about ♪
Brawny paper towels.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meanwhile, Netflix is coming out
with an interactive daily trivia
series called Trivia Quest.
Sounds fun, until you see
who's asking the questions.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some more entertainment news --
NBC just announced
a new reality show called
"Million Dollar Island,"
where they dump 100 contestants
on an island for 50 days, yeah.
They even have a cool name
for the show --
"Survivor."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a guy walking
through Times Square
dropped his wallet
with $4,000 inside,
then got it all back
after someone found it
and turned it in to the police.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah.
Then today, dozens of other
people went to the police like,
[ Haltingly ]
"I also lost a wallet
[ Laughter ]
with $4,000."
Police returned
the man's wallet,
then arrested him for whatever
he was planning to do
[ Laughter ]
in Times Square with $4,000.